SMP leader in Blackfoot thank you Mr
Speaker and can I still set myself with
the remarks of the Prime Minister for
Armistice we remember those that paid
the ultimate sacrifice those that
continue to serve and we should also
remember the nuclear test veterans who
continue to seek Justice for themselves
Mr Speaker
last night the Prime Minister suffered
the self-inflicted loss of its first
cabinet minister
a couple of weeks into the job it turns
out this prime minister's judgment is
everything better as bad as his
predecessors
speaking of which we now know that his
former friend the former prime minister
plans to hand out seats in the House of
Lords to at least four Tory MPS
including the current Secretary of State
for Scotland so here's another test of
judgment for the new prime minister does
he think it right to keep a man in the
cabinet who's clearly far more
interested and in getting his hands on
an airline road than playing by the
rules of Scottish democracy
[Applause]
Mr Speaker I'm obviously not going to
comment on speculation around such lists
any list would of course follow the
normal procedures and processes that are
in place
[Music]
I'm afraid it's uh not speculation and
of course the Prime Minister clearly
doesn't get how corrupt this all looks
to people in Scotland because not only
do we have a UK government that denies
democracy we now have a secretary of
state that is Running Scared from it in
the middle of a Tory cost of living
crisis so Scotland offers is now to be
led by a baron and waiting invading his
time until he can cash in on the 300-day
job for Life In The House of Lords he
should be psyched from the cabinet and
the people of Dumfries and Galloway
should be given the chance to sack the
Tony in a by-election the prime
minister's judgment is already intacted
if he has any Integrity left will he now
put a stop to these two assessors
stuffing the House of Lords up with his
Chronicles
[Music]
Mr Speaker what the Secretary of State
and I are jointly focused on is working
constructively with the Scottish
government to deliver for the people of
Scotland I'll be pleased to be meeting
the first Minister tomorrow because that
I think is what the people of Scotland
want to see